[Music]
this week we've got hella good oh yeah
six is good you want double down to get
it before you contaminate even get yours
at barbell brigade com2 Joe had to fart
and don't you make track your voice
parts really well what their breathable
they belong to you so just keep on oh
this is real he said they could only get
up and kick [ __ ] and do stuff if it's
real and it's real yep I smell it it's
really real re no The Cosby guys it
helps reset your nostrils that's what
they do at the mall that's the thing cuz
all the fragrance start smelling the
same so go here smell this okay reset
and it's a good ginger with that took a
palate cleanser yeah yeah this week we
got mister mom leaving bare and deadly
smell mr. mom Chinese hot mustard why is
that so funny I want to hear your
thought process with this pose like the
movie I can't see the it looks like a
cute little 90s poster with his all feet
it's a pretty face peers [ __ ] poster
yeah alright so mr. mom here this dad
his name is max you just say mr. mom yes
she's been saying it like my picture a
[ __ ] bearded walrus with a apron like
a literal Walt walrus or men that has a
body like a wallet no I picture a walrus
like a walrus like you like a real one I
got walrus yeah
a walrus like the cousin of a seal oh
yeah with the big teeth that looks like
a bald British man mr. nanny or
something I talking about Arnold
Schwarzenegger is it mr. mom it is mr.
ma mr. monk Oh was mr. monk okay all
right but this right here so max uh so
his you had the title yeah it didn't
sound like it was that Batman played him
right yeah Batman played him as well
Michael Keaton there we go
Oh I was seeing one Hulk Hogan Hulk
Hogan Hogan definitely play them a mom
picture him in a tutu I just think
you're right yeah cover her eyes in my
head didn't know her get pregnant a
movie - that's Junior junior him in
there was it Danny DeVito
yeah or that was twins but there was
another one where Otto got knocked out
yeah nine months
it's called nine months yeah I gotta
watch all these movies so this story
here so his wife named April she had
complications after she gave birth to
their daughter so she started like
seizing right after and so they really
wanted the baby to be breastfed
immediately after she was born
so this nurse asked max if he was down
to try on this contraption thing that
allows him to breastfeed the baby and so
he shared these photos on Facebook and
season all the baby sees his mom oh so
she couldn't in the mom couldn't
breastfeed yeah so the max would you
like to read due to complications during
April's emergency c-section the super
red nurse made an epically killer offer
and I was fortunate enough to slap on a
suction cup fake nipple last time being
the first to breastfeed the baby I did
it for the moms eat your heart out emoji
and mochi mochi mochi wait that's his
that's his real nipple no I'll show you
these are the photos he shared so it's
like a suction cup that attaches to his
nipple
yeah and then she everyone's pointing
out the fact that it says mom
good tattoo everyone's loving that
that's cute
don't they have those uh fake titties
that you could just put on like a bra
and then hold a baby and then there's
milk inside ah
I don't think you just had a great
business idea myself I thought they had
those where guys can be breastfeed to I
think you got that from Meet the Fockers
oh let me show you video clip ready yeah
poor baby
gotta suck on that hairy ass chance I
wonder if it's gonna be hard for it's a
suck on a regular nipple cuz it's used
to this plastic thing there's it was
just one time I'll try anything once and
everybody got pretty excited went for it
I think that's really what did it is the
one can see right there the baby didn't
what
when helped you go viral there pal Yeah
right
got the attention mm-hmm and then
they're saying that no dad has ever done
that before
in that hospital [ __ ] lame ass dads
yeah [ __ ] no I would never do that I
wouldn't do it I wouldn't do it if the
baby needed milk e1g hell no cuz that
makes me look feminine I don't give a
[ __ ] I want my baby my baby
needed it like they were like this close
to not being nourished I would say no
thank you
oh no at the expense of my man no
seizing yeah that's you seizing as you
doing salsa yeah hell yeah it's also
[ __ ] you guys I love how they play this
off against the breathers [ __ ] ever for
a guy to do that to me I'm like of
course you do that so what so what what
what are they really saying is that wow
he's such a cool dad because yeah so
they're saying that men need to [ __ ]
like not think there's so many because
if they're saying that's the first
that's crazy
what is unmanly about that though like
we got nipples too and it's not being
used
let the baby suck it use it or lose it
buddy yeah most people don't think that
we need a movement because like you said
we have nipples too and they're not
being used yeah it's not fair it's not
fair you should be shamed in public for
breastfeeding to everyone would bought
their nipples right now - the girls
before I got a pretty I got a suckle
titty we had actually it's pretty big
for we know what mindful touch
everybody's nipples in this room - yeah
we did it was soft yep some of really
good guy nipples we didn't have the
[ __ ] bravery did you girl netball -
no I guess it gets hard what doors Joe
it was saw I almost thought your nipple
was seasonable cuz you had a hair on it
he has a ring around the rosey no he has
all logic
he has chest hair and all you Asians
don't he's got bored don't [ __ ]
remember I pulled it off
you better get whiskey huh I don't think
examine you're really zoom in here
before that fires were invented I think
we just use guide nipple right we know
you're making sure we got no he knew
right away it wasn't it wasn't myself
this just sucks
daddy was like what kind of force them I
feel like I feel bad for the baby if
they have to suck on kindness
yeah it's gross yeah cuz the titties way
better way better over it meat it seemed
more like a girl nipple yeah it was like
longer yeah cuz you know like guys have
a [ __ ] hairy ass rough skin or like
it's just different and it's just isn't
there's no softness we're disgusting
yeah I'm good it's a hard peck yeah it
means transphobic but does a baby like
chew on that [ __ ] they do they do
yeah there's an effort what do you do
you just like god damn no you put a
finger in there you tell them no oh
really
but they're still gonna do it I mean I
do I risk that Isaac till he was nine
months and he had teeth but him you're
not some good bite on me you know what's
funny um when when Tiger was a month ago
the year
yeah when Tiger was a baby baby baby and
I will hold him he's he's not looking
for a nipple and I thought that was so
weird cuz before huh maybe he wasn't
hungry Oh cuz like every time I help my
nephew or niece like they were
immediately start look for the nipple
and in there their head I could feel him
going like this like look at my nipple
looking for knit wool yeah you would do
that when he was hungry yard needs with
full-on grabbed his boobs old oh yeah
looking for a nipple so for next door
it's right there right there right not
normal yeah that's right there it's like
right there hearing like crunching
leaves crunching take some rustling here
yeah there's some rustling and then
that's when cuz he thought it was just
his neighbor doing some gardening but
then like if the sounds grew louder and
louder so he looked over it in my yard
Jorge and it was a bear
remember he's holding the margarita inna
- I feel like it's not that weird cuz
young Idina that's like in the mountains
Altadena is like yeah the mountains
black neighborhood he's an agent in
black neighbor yeah Alto Deena's like
they have a lot of black people there
and Asians
really I really see in Asians oh yeah
whoa good thing you can March makeup H
Oh ugh please pronounce that Hou gh
below-market Oh what's safe what's that
play area like chuck-e-cheese for adults
that Dave and Buster's don't have a day
with masters in Altadena what I know
that I've got one here man no Evan
anyways like he was in the backyard he
saw that there was this bear climbing
over his fence but he did elect his more
greetings I got out and then he
sacrifices Marguerita you did you could
take it with you when you run but he was
it was it a full group in there I'm
gonna show you a video there's a video
thank goodness for phones
he's got a tag on yeah he was chilling
jacuzzi he drank the margarita he drink
a margarita
cuz it's sweet don't bake a and then
sometime later after he left the this
man's jacuzzi he noticed that the bear
was sleeping on one of the trees and he
was like he had a little margarita and
then he took in that they sleep on trees
he's like I found a resort that's why if
you ever run into a bear you're [ __ ]
cuz they run [ __ ] fast they climb
they swim like they're unstoppable
I was super close to a bear near that
Altadena area yeah oh yeah that's scary
too though and the moms around yep
that [ __ ] was so ugly it looked like a
possum face bear yeah oh this is how
close were you to it uh it was like from
me to a little bit past year that's
pretty [ __ ] close Ranger didn't let
me get that close cuz he controlled
somehow no well it was a parking lot
area and we were walking up and then
Ranger was driving down he's like
there's a bear up there so you got a
steak far away from it and I was like oh
there's a bear so then I went up and
then as I was getting kind of close to
another Ranger came by
yeah why I wanted to pick him but but
the bear was on what was a cub and it
was like so is the size of maybe a
pitbull so it's very it's like it's like
this big it was like that big any work
you up I'm afraid of the Mambo exactly
not the baby I'm gonna but it was on top
of a car it was on a car okay then you
could pet him now yeah you good story I
can't make it to JK news there's a bear
oh my god
if I see a baby bear I'm gonna do
everything that I can there's Pettit
mm-hmm just to let you know just to let
you know I'm not paying for your [ __ ]
hospital bills I'm not I'm just not know
if you don't really see me I'm gonna
tell taiko your father was a [ __ ]
idiot it's a bear Petter a successful
bear better do you think this is what
always happens you find a little baby
cub bear and you're petting the bear and
you're taking selfies with in their
video or some stupid ass [ __ ] and then
the mama bear comes but it always
happens
what can they run fast yeah they're
super fast that's a more Cal bear right
I think they got like 25 or 30 miles
they're [ __ ] fast what the [ __ ] a
bear go 30 miles an hour she does the
only animal that goes faster than it
they're [ __ ] fast dude damn and
they're [ __ ] claws are like you green
man what the bear how are we the top of
the food chain then don't break that's
why you're bro good germs of Steel okay
cuz I'm a little bit worried we should
eradicate all these [ __ ] bears of
then why did nature make bear cubs
why did nature make bear cubs for so
[ __ ] cute then I know
yeah they shouldn't have done that to
let them last though because we don't
kill them
you should pet them natural selection I
will pepper I'm letting you know I will
why is this like an intervention would
you prefer like Gio just so you know I
will try to Pender know everything in my
power with my body I will I will say
when bears are doing human [ __ ] cues
should I ever saw I love it no our last
story yeah white like one of those
circus balls oh [ __ ] thing that's
cute
so for our last story this Russian rock
star has died after suffering severe
tissue de cosas saw flesh-eating
bacteria damp and so this made headlines
because he was on a plane
and the flight had to be diverted
because the smell intention so much that
people were vomiting on my dad on the
plane he didn't die on the plane he died
a stroke but like his being like so this
may was Andre shoot Xuan 58 years old
yes so that's the rock star yeah he used
to he used to be a Russian rock it's
like an Aerosmith
maybe all right I don't know if he's
that sad urge he was actively playing
music but he he was really famous in
Russia man he'd she disappointed me what
because he didn't have a rock star death
yeah cuz I'm picturing like that no
picture of gene say no like like you
know even like in a Hawaiian shirt but
but it's because he's in a Hawaiian
shirt and [ __ ] that's actually more
metal comparatively because everyone
dresses the same man I guess what that
he's a counterculture Avril Lavigne came
out I started dressing preppy because
all the cheerleaders start addressing
punk rock happens every time so now he's
the edgy guy
exactly he's wearing Bermuda shorts a
pith helmet
he's counterculture so what kind of
bacteria was it a flesh-eating kind but
they don't really say where exactly he
got it but apparently he got this this
infection when he was in the Canary
Islands oh [ __ ] that
that's the worst Canary Islands I don't
know there's a bunch of Canaries on it
hahaha you been there yeah and Turkey
there's so many turkeys all over to any
not hungry everybody's starving no
button here that you're so well just
good french fries because there's so
much grease I hate this game it's so
cold and Iceland it's so green and
Greenland mom jokes are way worse than
bad jobs yeah my mom goes well jokes
aren't even mom I'm a cool kid you're a
cat mom it's true there used to be
Indians but we took care of that
anyway so yeah the canary I lived there
in Spain we were curious we guys so it
was just pretty crazy because they
actually so they the flight crew were
trying to like have him did he know that
he was [ __ ] infected and she went to
the hospital and they told him like oh
it's just a beach the beach infection
and I don't worry you'll be fine
but it turned out to be a flesh-eating
bacteria and then yeah did you know he
smelled yeah he could smell it too I
mean he was still alive when that
happened what do you think he had you
know what the smell I'm I'm I could
smell right now foot fungus no oh I
never smelled that is when you have a
band-aid on and then like go ahead it on
for too long and then that smell
the plugs no I smelled that band-aid
smell more than that cuz a bend it has
like this rubbery like smell to it I was
there saying that like passengers
described it as though he hadn't taken a
shower for week damn that sucks you died
with the whole like bunch of people like
you stayed look you get out of here and
then you [ __ ] it
Bayden you die yeah he actually she
wrote on Facebook shortly after the
emergency landing he said she was on the
stretcher like this I don't know where
exactly he was so he said the tragic and
comic component of this whole situation
is that I caught a disease which
parenthesis let's not say how and why
makes a person quite stinky as a result
a group of passengers may demand the
captain for you to be removed from the
plane but he died right died in the
hospital
dude one time we were sitting there
Smith kid on the plane that had the
worst smelling breath I have ever had I
literally almost vomited everywhere as
you can see we are predominantly in East
Coast be a there's gonna be a quiz on
all this later I'm just kidding someone
said that to me once now I say it it was
so good sleep Linda you just like smell
but the entire part of the plane it was
so bad fella
yeah it was halitosis and he was like I
got say something those kids would you
tell me man she had to sit next to the
killer you gotta say I was gonna say
your buddy let me let me buy you all the
[ __ ] mints in the world right now
I'll spend $25 no really what would you
say no really I was gonna buy a bunch of
gum where's your body we were on the
plane we're on a plane where they have a
bunch of [ __ ] like you think the
stewardesses don't have no gum no we did
you know that stewardesses and pilots
and all anything I all [ __ ] each
other so you better believe they got
like a pack of sir so when you [ __ ] you
have gum I don't have gum I have gone
when we [ __ ] so I I never have gum we
know yeah yep she said they're watching
this and she's like it's like she's in
the death room in mafia right now she's
like [ __ ] I know I don't have gummy
there and I always drink coffee and I'm
he always tries to kiss me and I'm like
I just drank coffee he's like I don't
care you smell great
she does she smells good
[Music]